the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
data points and then I do it again do it
again and again then in average the
number I should get should be close to
the true parameter that I'm looking for
the fluctuations that are due to the
fact that I get different samples every
time should somewhat vanish and so what
I want is to have a small bias hopefully
a zero bias if this thing is zero then
we say that the estimator is unbiased
okay so this is definitely a property
that we're gonna look be looking for and
estimator trying to find them to be
unbiased but we'll see that it's
actually maybe not enough all right so
one biasness should not be something you
don't you lose your sleep over something
that's slightly better is the risk
so really the quadratics risk which is
expectation of so if I have an estimator
theta hat I'm gonna look at the
expectation of theta hat n minus theta
squared and what we showed last time is
that we can actually by inserting in
there adding and removing the
expectation of theta hat we actually get
something where this thing can be
decomposed as the square of the bias
plus the variance which is just the
expectation of theta hat minus its
expectation
squared okay that came from the fact
that when I added and removed the
expectation of theta hat in there the
cross terms canceled all right so that
was the bias squared and this is the
variance okay and so for example if the
static risk goes to zero then that means
that theta hat converges to theta in the
l2 sense and and here we know that if we
want this to go to zero this is the sum
of two positive terms we need to have
both the bias that goes to zero and the
variance that goes to zero so we need to
control both of those things and so
there is usually an inherent trade-off
between getting a small bias and getting
a small variance if you reduce one too
much then the variance of the other one
is gonna increase then the other one is
gonna increase or the opposite that
happens a lot but not so much actually
in this class so let's just look at a
couple of examples right
so examples so if I do for example X 1 X
n that are IID Bernoulli and I'm gonna
write it theta so that we keep the same
notation then theta hat what is the
theta hat that we proposed many times
it's just X bar right xn bar the average
of the x i's so what is the bias of this
guy well to know the bias I just have to
remove data from the expectation what is
the expectation of xn of xn bar well by
linearity of the expectation is just the
average of the expectations but since
all my x i's are burning with the same
theta then each of this guy is actually
equal to theta so this thing is actually
theta which means that this isn't biased
right ok now what is the variance of
this guy okay so if you forgot the
properties of the variance for sum of
independent random variables now it's
time to wake up so we have the variance
of something that looks like 1 over n
sum from I equal 1 to N of X I right so
it's of the form variance of a constant
times a random variable so the first
thing I'm gonna do is pull out the
constant but we know that the variance
lives on the squares scale so when I
pull out a constant outside of the
variance it comes out with a square
right the variance of a times X is a
squared times the variance of X so this
is equal to 1 over N squared times the
variance of the sum so now we want to
always do what we want to do right so we
have the variance of the sum we would
like somehow to see that this is the sum
of the variances and in general we are
now allowed to say that but we are
because my X eyes are actually
independent
right so this is actually equal to one
over N squared sum from I equal 1 to N
of the variance of each of the X I and
that's by independence okay so this is
basic probability and now what is the
variance of exercise where again they're
all the same distribution so the
variance of X is the same as the
variance of X 1 and so each of those
guys is variance what what is the
variance of a Bernoulli we've said it
once it's theta a times 1 minus state ok
and so now I'm gonna have the sum of n
times the constant so I get n times the
constant divided by n square so one of
the n is gonna cancel and so the whole
thing here is actually equal to theta 1
minus theta divided by n so if I'm
interested in the ecstatic risk and
again I should just say risk because
this is the only risk we're gonna be
actually looking at yeah this
parenthesis should really stop here I
really wanted to put the dratted compare
anthesis so the risk of this guy is what
well is the expectation of X bar and
minus theta squared and we know it's the
square of the variance so it's the
square of the bias which we know is zero
so it's zero squared plus the variance
which is theta 1 plus theta 1 minus
theta divided by n ok so it's just fader
1 minus theta divided by n so this is
just summarizing the performance of an
estimator which is a random variable I
mean it's complicated if I really wanted
to describe it I would just tell you the
entire distribution of this random
variable but now what I'm doing is I'm
saying well let's just take this random
variable remove theta from it and see
how small the fluctuations around theta
n squared the squared fluctuations
around theta are
expectation all right so that's what the
quadratic risk is doing and in a way
this decomposition is the sum of the by
square and the variance is really
telling you that it it it is really
accounting for the bias which is well
even if I had an infinite amount of
observation it's this thing doing the
right thing and the other thing is
actually the variance so for finite
number of observations what are the
fluctuations all right then you can see
that those things bias and variance are
actually very different so so I don't
have any colors here so you're gonna
have to really follow the speed of the
the order in which I draw those curves
all right so let's find I'm gonna give
you three candidates estimators so
estimators for theta okay so the first
one is definitely xn bar that will be a
good candidate estimator the second one
is gonna be 0.5 because you know after
all why should I bother if it's actually
gonna be right so you know if it for
example if I ask you to predict the
score of some candidate in some election
then since you know it's gonna be very
close to 0.5 you might as well just
throw out 0.5 in you're not gonna be
very far from reality and it's actually
gonna cost you zero time in $0 to come
up with this so sometimes you know maybe
just a good old guess is actually doing
the job for you of course for candid
presidential elections or something like
this is not very helpful if your
prediction is telling you this but you
know I said was something different that
would be a good way to generate some
close to one for a coin for example
right if I give you a coin you never
know maybe it's slightly biased but the
good guess just looking at it expecting
it maybe there's something crazy
happening with the structure of it
you're gonna guess that it's point five
without trying to collect information
and let's find another one which is well
you know I have a lot of observations
but you know I'm recording this couples
kissing but you know I am on a budget I
don't have time to travel all around the
world and collect some people so really
I'm just gonna look at the first couple
and go home so my father estimators
dx1 all right I just take the first
observation zero one and that's it okay
so now I'm gonna I want to actually
understand what the behavior of those
guys is alright so we know and so we
know that for this guy the bias is 0 and
the variance is equal to theta 1 minus
theta divided by n okay what is the bias
of this guy 0.5 0.5 minus theta right so
the bias 0.5 minus theta what is the
variance of this guy what is the
variance of 0.5 zero right just the
deterministic number so there's no
fluctuations for this guy
what is the bias well x1 is actually
just for simplicity I can think of it as
being x1 bar the average of itself so
that wherever I saw an end for this guy
I can replace it by 1 and that will give
me my formula so the bias is still going
to be 0 and the variance is going to be
equal to theta 1 minus theta ok so now I
have those three estimators well if I
compare x1 and X and bar then clearly I
have 0 bias in both cases that's good
and I have the variance that's actually
n times smaller and when I use my n
observations than when I don't so those
two guys on this two front you can
actually look at the two numbers and say
well the first number is the same the
second number is better for the other
guy so I will definitely go for this guy
compared to this guy all right so this
guy is going but not this guy well if I
look at the bias the variance is 0 it's
always beating the variance of this guy
and if I look at the bias it's actually
really not that bad right at 0.5 minus
theta in particular if theta is 0.5 then
this guy is strictly better and so you
can actually now look at what the the
dratted risk looks like
all right so here what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take my truth theta so
it's going to range between 0 and 1 and
we know that those two things are
functions of theta so I can only
understand them if I plot them as
functions of theta all right and so now
I'm going to actually plot the y axis is
going to be the risk okay
so what is the risk of the estimator 0.5
this one is easy well it's 0 plus the
square of 0.5 minus theta okay
so we know that that's theta it's
actually going to be 0 and then it's
going to be a square so at 0 is going to
be 0.25 and at 1 it's gonna be 0.25 as
well so it looks like this actually sir
let me put the point 5 where it should
be okay so this here is the risk of 0.5
I'll write it like this okay so when
theta is very close to 0.5 I'm very
happy when theta I gets large farther
it's a little less a little bit annoying
and then here I want to plot the risk of
this guy so another thing with the risk
of this guy is that it will depend on n
so I will just pick some n that I'm
happy with just so that I can actually
draw a line of a curve otherwise I'm
gonna have to plot one curve for value
of n so let's just say for example that
n is equal to 10 and so now I need to
plot the function theta 1 minus theta
divided by 10 alright we know that theta
1 minus theta is a curve that goes like
this it takes value at one half it takes
value 1/4 that's the maximum and it's
zero at the end okay so really if n is
equal to 1 this is what the variance
looks like right device doesn't count in
the risk yeah
sure can you move all right are you guys
good all right so now I have this
picture and I know I'm going to up to 25
and there's a place where those curves
cross so if you're sure let's say you're
talking about that presents an election
you know that those things are gonna be
really close maybe you're actually
better by predicting 0.5 if you know
it's not gonna go too far but that's
through one observation right so that's
the risk of x1 but if I look at the risk
of xn all I'm doing is just crushing
this curve down to zero so as n
increases is gonna look more and more
like this it's the same curve divided by
n okay
and so now I can just start to
understand that for different values of
Thetas now I'm gonna have to be very
close to theta is equal to one half if I
want to start saying that xn bar is
worse than the naive estimator is your
0.5 okay yeah so either you can well
when you have an unbiased estimator it's
simple it's just telling you is the
variance right because the theta that
you have over there is really right so
in the definition of the risk the theta
that you have here if you're in biased
is really the expectation of theta hat
right so that's really just the variance
so the risk is really telling you how
much fluctuations I have around my
expectation if I'm biased but actually
here is telling you how much
fluctuations I have an average around
theta so if you understand the notion of
variance as being what now it's just
like variance so when you I mean if you
claim you understand what variances it's
telling you what is the expected
expected squared fluctuation around the
expectation of my random variable right
they're telling you in average how far
I'm gonna be and you take this square
because you want to cancel the signs
otherwise you're gonna get 0 and here
it's saying well I really don't care
what the expectation of theta hat is
what I want to get to is theta so I'm
looking at
the expectation of the squared
fluctuations around theta itself if I'm
Minh biased they coincide coincide with
the variance but if I'm biased then I
have to account for the fact that I'm
really not computing the okay all right
are there any questions so here what I
really want to illustrate is that the
risk itself is a function of theta and
most of the times and so for different
data some estimators are gonna be better
than others but there's also the entire
range of estimators those that are
really biased but the bias completely
vanish and so here you see you have no
bias but the variance can be large or
you have zero bias so you have a bias
but the variance is zero you can
actually have this trade-off and you can
find things that are in the entire range
okay in general okay
so those things are actually those
trade-offs between bias and variance are
usually much better Illustrated if we're
talking about multivariate parameters if
I actually look at a parameter which is
the mean of some multivariate Gaussian
so an entire vector then the bias is
gonna I can make the bias bigger by
making by for example forcing all the
coordinates of my estimator to be the
same so here I'm gonna get some bias but
the variance is actually getting much
better because I get to average all the
coordinates for this guy
and so really the bias-variance tradeoff
is when you have a multiple parameters
to estimate it's a vector of parameters
a multivariate parameter is the bias
increases when you're trying to pull
more information across the different
components at the to actually have a
lower variance okay so the more you
average the lower the variance right
that's exactly what we've Illustrated as
n increases the variance decreases like
1 over N or theta of 1 minus 3 over N
and so this is how it happens in general
in this class it's mostly one
dimensional parameter estimation so it's
gonna be a little harder to illustrate
that but if you do for example non
parametric estimation that's all you do
there's like just wise variants trade
offs all the time okay and in between
when you have high dimensional
parametric estimation that happens a lot
as well okay so I'm just gonna go
quickly through those two remaining
slides because we've actually seen them
but I
just wanted you to have somewhere a
formal definition of what a confidence
interval is and so we fixed a
statistical model for n observations X 1
to X n the parameter theta here is one
dimensional theta is a subset of the
real line and that's why I call I talk
about intervals right that interval is a
subset of the line if I had a subset of
R 2 for example that would no longer be
called an interval but a region okay
just because that's just we could see a
set but confidence sets but people like
to say conference region okay so an
interval is just a one-dimensional
conference region and it has to be an
interval as well okay so a confidence
interval of level 1 minus alpha all
right so we refer to the quality of a
confidence interval is actually called
its level it takes value 1 minus alpha
for some positive alpha and so the
confidence level the level of the
confidence interval is between 0 & 1 the
closer to 1 it is the better the
confidence interval the closer to 0 the
worse it is okay and so for any random
interval so a confidence interval is a
random interval the bounds of this
interval depends on random data all
right just like we had x-bar plus minus
1 1 over square root of n for example or
two over square root of n this x-bar was
the random thing that would make
fluctuate those guys all right and so
now I have an interval and now I have
its boundaries but now the boundaries
are not allowed to depend on my unknown
parameter otherwise it's not a
confidence interval just like an
estimator that depends on the unknown
parameter is not an estimator
all right the conference interval has to
be something that I can compute once I
collect data and so what I want is that
so there's this weird notation the fact
that I write theta that I can't in so
that's the probability that I contains
theta you're used to seeing theta
belongs to I but here I really want to
emphasize that the randomness is in I
and so the way you actually say it when
you read this formula is the probability
that I contains theta is at least 1
minus alpha all right so it better be
close to 1 right you want one - ow
to be very close to one because it's
really telling you that whatever random
variable I'm giving you my error bars
are actually covering the right theta
okay and I want this to be true but I
want this since I don't know what my
confidence my parameter theta is I want
this to hold true for all possible
values of the parameters that nature may
have company have come up with from okay
so I want this so there's theta that
changes here so the distribution of the
interval is actually changing with theta
hopefully and theta is changing with
this guy so regardless of the value of
theta that I'm getting I want that the
probability that it contains the theta
is actually larger than one minus alpha
okay so I'll come back to in a second I
just want to say that here we have we
can talk about asymptotic level and
that's typically when you use central
limit theorem to control to compute this
guy then you're not guaranteed that the
value is at least one minus alpha for
every n but it's actually in the limit
larger than one minus alpha
okay so if I may be for each fix then
it's going to be not true but for as n
goes to infinity it's actually going to
become true if you want this to hold for
every N you actually need to use things
such as have things in equality that we
described at some point okay so as a
rule of thumb once you if you use the
central limit theorem you're dealing
with a confidence interval with
asymptotic level one minus alpha and the
reason is because you actually want to
get some the quintiles of the normal the
Gaussian distribution that comes from
the central limit theorem and if you
want to use huffing for example you
might actually get away with a
confidence interval that's actually true
even not asymptotically just the regular
comfortable okay so this is the formal
definition it's a bit of a mouthful but
we actually the best way to understand
them is to build them all right now at
some point I said and I think it was
part of the homework right so here I
really say the probability the true
parameter belongs to the confidence
interval is actually 1 minus alpha and
so that's because here this confidence
interval is still a random variable now
if I start plugging in numbers instead
of the random variables x1 to xn I start
putting 1
zero one zero zero zero one like I did
for the kiss example then in this case
the random interval is actually going to
be 0.42 0.65 and this guy the
probability data belongs to it is not
one minus alpha
it's just either zero if it's not in
there or 20 fits in there okay so so
there's here's the example that we had
right so just let's look at back into
our you know favorite example which is
the average of Bernoulli random
variables so we studied that maybe
that's the third time already so the
sample average xn bar is a strongly
consistent estimator of P right that was
one of the properties that we wanted
this strongly consistent means that as n
goes to infinity converges almost surely
to the true parameter that's the strong
law of large number it is consistent
also because it's strong consistent so
it also comes all the converges in
probability which makes it consistent
it's in biased we've seen that we've
actually computed it's a quadratic risk
and now what I have is that if I look at
thanks to the central limit theorem we
actually did this we built a confidence
interval at level one minus alpha
right asymptotic level sorry asymptotic
level one minus alpha
alright and so here this is how we did
it let me just go through it again so we
know from the central limit theorem
so the central limit theorem tells us
that xn bar minus P divided by square
root of P 1 minus P square root of n
converges and distribution as n goes to
infinity to some standard normal
distribution right so what it means is
that if I look at the probability under
the true P that's greater than xn bar
minus P divided by square root of P 1
minus P is less than Q alpha over 2
where this is the definition of the
quintile then this guy and I'm actually
going to use the write the same notation
limit as n goes to infinity right this
is the same thing right so this is
actually going to be equal to 1 minus
alpha right that's exactly what I did
last time this is by definition of the
quantile of a standard Gaussian and of
limiting distribution okay so the
probabilities computed on this guy as in
the limit converges to the probability
computer on this guy and we know that
this is just the probability the
absolute value of some n0 1 is less than
Q alpha over 2 okay and so in particular
if it's equal then I can put them larger
than or equal to which guarantees my
asymptotic confidence level and I just
solved for P all right so this is
equivalent to the limit as n goes to
infinity of the probability that theta
is between xn bar minus Q alpha over 2
divided by x square root of P 1 minus P
divided by Sturdevant xn bar plus Q
alpha over 2 square root of P 1 minus P
divided by square root of n is larger
than or equal to 1 minus alpha and so
there you go I have my confidence
interval
except that not right we just said that
the balance of a confidence interval may
not depend on the unknown parameter and
here they do and so we actually came up
with two ways of getting rid of this
since we only need this thing so this
thing as we said is really equal
every time I'm gonna make this guy
smaller and this guy larger I'm only
going to increase the probability and so
what we do is we actually just take the
largest possible value for P one minus P
which makes the interval as large as
possible okay and so now I have this I
just do one of the two tricks I replace
P 1 minus P by their upper bound which
is 1/4 okay as we said P 1 minus P the
function looks like this so I just take
the value here at 1/2 or I can use
Slutsky and say that if I replace P by
xn bar but it's the same as just
replacing P by xn bar here and by
Slutsky we know that this is actually
converging also to some standard
Gaussian
oK we've seen that when we saw Slutsky
as an example all right and so those two
things actually just because I'm taking
the limit and I'm only caring about the
asymptotic confidence level I can
actually just plug in consistent
quantities in there such as xn bar where
I don't have a P and that gives me
another contrast number all right so
this by now hopefully after doing it
three times you should really really be
comfortable with just creating this
conference interval right we did it
three times in class I think you
probably did it another couple times in
your homework so just make sure you're
comfortable with this all right that's
one of the basic things you would want
to know are there any questions so we're
yes
so that's not Slutsky right so so so
Slutsky tells you that if you stucks is
about combining two types of convergence
right so Slutsky tells you that if you
actually have one xn that converges to X
and distribution and yn that converges
to Y in probability then you can
actually multiply xn and yn and get that
the limiting distribution is the product
of X and X and y where X is now a
constant okay and here we have the
constant which is 1 okay so but I did
that already right
using Slutsky to replace it for the FIR
to replace PN P by xn bar we've done
that last time maybe a couple times ago
actually yeah that's correct
so of course the answer the short answer
is no for so here's how I would you
would go about thinking about which
might let it better right so there's
always the more conservative method the
first one the only thing you're losing
is the rate of convergence of the
central limit theorem all right so it's
essentially if n is large enough so that
the central limit theorem approximation
is very good then that's all you're
gonna be you're gonna be losing right of
course the price to pace that you're
comfortable is wider than it would be if
you were to use let's key for this
particular problem right typically wider
actually it is always wider all right
and so because xn bar my 1 minus xn bar
is always less than 1/4 as well and so
so that's that's that's the first the
first thing you know so Slutsky
basically adds you're relying on the
central limit you're relying on these
synthetics again now of course you don't
want to be conservative because you
actually want to squeeze as much from
your data as you can right so it depends
on how comfortable and how critical it
is for you to put a valid error bars
right if they're valid in this entire
extend maybe you're actually gonna go
with Slutsky so it actually gives you
slightly narrower confidence intervals
and and so you feel like you're a little
more company you you have a more precise
answer now if you really need to be
super conservative then you're actually
gonna go with a with the P 1 minus P
actually if you need to be even more
conservative you were gonna go with hub
ding so you don't even have to rely on
the asymptotic level at all but then
your comforts interval becomes twice as
wide and twice as wide and it becomes
wider and wider as you go right so
depends on the I mean there's a lot of
that in statistics which is you know
gauging how critical it is for you to
output valid error bounds or if they're
really just here to be indicative of you
know the precision of the estimator that
you you gave from a more qualitative
perspective yeah so here there's
basically a bunch of errors there's one
that's so there's a theorem called bear
yes and that qualifies how far this
probability is from 1 minus alpha
but the constants are terrible so
they're it's not very helpful but it
tells you as n grows how smaller this
thing is growth becomes smaller and then
for Slutsky
again you're multiplying something that
converges by something that fluctuates
around one so you need to understand how
this thing fluctuates now there's
something that shows up is basically
what is the slope of the function 1 over
square root of x 1 minus x around the
value you're interested in and so if
this function is super sharp then small
fluctuations of xn bar around its
expectation they're going to lead to
really high fluctuations in the function
itself right so if you're looking at if
you have F of xn bar and F around say
the true P if F is really sharp like
that then if you move a little bit here
then you're gonna move really that's
what the function here the function
you're interested in is 1 over square
root of X 1 minus X right so what does
this function look like around the point
where you think P's the true parameter
it's derivative really is what's matters
okay any other question ok so it's
important because now we're gonna switch
to the real you know let's do some
hardcore computation type of thing
alright so in this chapter we're going
to talk about maximum likelihood
estimation who has already seen maximum
likelihood estimation okay and who knows
what a convex function is okay so we'll
do a little bit of reminders on those
things so those things are when we do
maximum likelihood estimation and
likelihood is a function so we need to
maximize a function that's basically
what we need to do and if I give you a
function you need to know how to
maximize this function sometimes you
have closed form solutions you can take
the derivative and put a set it equal to
zero and solve it but sometimes you
actually need to resort to algorithms to
do that then there's an entire industry
doing that
and and we'll briefly touched upon it
but this is definitely not the focus of
this class okay so before diving
directly into the definition of the
likelihood and what is the definition of
the maximum likelihood estimator what
I'm going to try to do is to give you an
insight for what we're actually doing
when we do maximum likely estimation
okay so remember we have a model on the
sample space Yi and some candidate
distributions P theta and really your
goal is to estimate a true theta star
the one that generated some data x1 to
xn in an iid fashion but this theta star
is really a proxy for us to know that we
actually understand the distribution
itself the goal of knowing P state of
knowing theta star is so that you can
actually know what p theta star is right
otherwise it has well sometimes we said
it has some meaning itself but really
you want to know what the distribution
is and so your goal is to actually come
up with the distribution hopefully that
comes from the family P theta that's
close to p theta star okay so in a way
what does it mean to have two
distributions that are close it means
that when you compute probabilities on
one distributions you should have the
same probability on the other
distribution pretty much all right so
what we can do we say well now I have
two candidate distributions so theta hat
leads to a candidate distribution p
theta hat and this is the truth theta
star that leads to the true distribution
p theta star according to which my data
was drawn okay
that's my candidate as a statistician
I'm supposed to come up with a good
candidate and this is the truth okay and
what I want is that if you actually give
me the distribution then I want one I'm
computing probabilities for this guy I
know what the probabilities for the
other guys are okay and so really what I
want is that if
computes a probability under stata hats
of some interval a B it should be pretty
close to the probability under status
star of a b and more generally if i want
to take the union of two intervals i
want this to be true if i take just half
lines i want this to be true from 0 to
infinity for example things like this i
want this to be true for all of them at
once and so what i do is that i write a
for a probability event and I want that
p hat of a is close to p star of a for
any event a in the sample space right
does that sound like a reasonable goal
for a statistician okay so in particular
if I want those two because I want the
absolute value of their difference to be
close to zero all right and this turns
out to be if I want this to hold for all
possible A's right I have all possible
events so I'm gonna actually maximize
over this events and I'm gonna look at
the worst possible event on which theta
hat can depart from theta star and so
rather than defining it specifically for
theta hat and theta star I'm just gonna
say well if you give me two probability
measures P theta and P theta prime I
want to know how close they are well if
I want to measure how close they are by
how they can defer when I measure the
probability of some event I'm just
looking at the absolute value of the
difference of the probabilities and I'm
just maximizing over the worst possible
event that might actually make them
defer agreed that's a pretty strong
notion so if the total variation between
theta and theta prime is small then it
means that for all possible aids that
you give me then P theta of a is gonna
be close to P theta prime of a alright
so because if let's say I just found the
balance of bound on the total variation
distance which is 0.01
all right so that means that this is
going to be larger than the max over a
of P theta minus P theta prime of a okay
so which means that for any a actually
let me write P theta hat and P theta
star like we said did a hat and theta
star and so if I have a balancing on the
total variation which is 0.01 that means
that P theta hat every time I compute a
probability on P theta hat it's
basically in the interval P theta star
of a there's one that I really wanted to
compute plus or minus 0.01 okay this has
nothing to do with conference interval
is just telling me how far I am from the
value I'm actually trying to compute
okay and that's true for all a and
that's key that squared this Max comes
into play it just says I want this to
this bound to hold for all possible a's
at once okay so this is actually very
well known distance between probability
measures it's the total variation
distance it's extremely central into
probabilistic analysis and it
essentially tells you that every time if
two probabilities tribution czar close
that it means that every time a computer
probability under p theta but I really
fit I really actually have data from p
theta prime then the error is no larger
than the Toleration okay so this is
maybe not the most convenient way of
defining a distance right I mean how are
you gonna you know in reality how are
you gonna compute this maximum over all
possible events I mean it's just crazy
right there's an infinite number of them
it's it's much larger than the number of
intervals for example so it's a bit
annoying and so there's actually a way
to compress it by just looking at the
basically function distance or vector
distance between pair
math functions or probability density
function okay so I'm gonna start with
the discrete version of the total
variation so throughout this chapter I
will make the difference between
discrete random variables and continuous
random variables it really doesn't
matter all that means is that when I
talk about discrete I will talk about
probability mass functions and when I
talk about continuous I will talk about
probability density functions when I
talk about probability functions
probability mass functions I talk about
sums when I talk about probability
density functions I talk about integrals
but they're all the same thing really
okay so let's start with the probability
mass function right everybody remembers
what the probability mass function of a
discrete random variable is this is the
function that tells me for each possible
value that it can take the probability
they takes this value alright so the
probability mass function PMF it's just
a function for all X in the sample space
tells me the probability that my random
variable is equal to this little value
okay and I will denote it by P sub theta
of X so what I want is of course that
the sum of the probabilities is 1 and I
want them to be non-negative actually
typically we will assume that they're
positive otherwise we can just remove
this X from the sample space okay and so
then I have the the tool variation
distance I mean it's supposed to be the
maximum over all sets of of subsets of e
such that the probability of theta minus
/ of a minus probability center prime of
a it's complicated but really there's
this beautiful formula that tells me
that if I look at the total variation
between P theta and peas that are prime
it's actually equal to just one half of
the sum for all X in E of the absolute
difference between
P theta X and P theta prime of X okay so
that's something you can compute if I
give you two probability mass functions
you can compute this immediately but if
I give you just the density's and the
original distribution the original
definition where you have to max over
all possible events it's not very gonna
be able to do that very quickly alright
so this is really the the one you can
work with but the other one is really
telling you what it's doing for you it's
controlling the difference of
probabilities you can compute on any
event but here is just telling you well
if you do it for each simple event its
act little X it's actually simple now if
we have continuous random variables
right so by the way I didn't mention but
discreet means bernly binomial but not
only does that have finite support like
by newly
bernly as support of size to binomial
and PS support of size N and there's n
possible values it can take but also
Poisson right Westone distribution can
take an infinite number of values right
all the positive integers non-negative
integers okay and so now we have also
the continuous one such as Gaussian
exponential and what characterizes those
guys is that they have a probability
density okay so the density remember the
way I use my density is when I want to
compute the probability of belonging to
some event a the probability X falling
to some subset of the rail line a is
simply the integral of the density on
this set all right that's the famous
area under the curve thing all right so
since for each possible value the
probability at X so I hope you remember
that stuff that's just probably
something that you must remember from
probability but essentially we know that
the probability at X is equal to little
X is zero for a continuous random
variable for all possible X's right
there's just none of them that actually
gets weight so what we have to do is to
describe the fact that it's in some
little region
so the probability that it's on in some
interval say a B this is the integral
between a and B of F theta of X DX okay
so I have this density such as the
Gaussian one and the probability that
I'd belong to the interval a B is just
the area under the curve between a and B
okay if you don't remember that please
take it
remedy okay so this function f just like
P is non-negative and rather than
something to one it integrates to 1 when
I integrate over the entire sample space
E and now the total variation well it
takes basically the same form right I
said that you essentially replace sums
by integrals when you're dealing with
densities and here it's just saying
rather than having half of the sum of
the absolute values you have half of the
integral of the absolute again if I give
you two densities and if you're not too
bad at calculus which you will often be
because there's lots of them you can
actually not compute
but if I give you for example two
Gaussian densities exponential minus x
squared blah blah blah and I say just
compute the total variation distance you
could actually write it as an integral
now whether you can actually reduce this
integral to some particular number is
another story but you could technically
do it right and so now so you have
actually a handle on this thing you
could technically ask Mathematica where
as asking Mathematica to take the max
over all possible events is gonna be
difficult alright so the total variation
has some properties just so let's look
let's keep on the board the definition
that involves say the densities okay so
think Gaussian in your mind and you have
two Gaussian one with min theta and one
with mean beta Prime and I'm looking at
a total variation between those two guys
okay so if I look at P theta minus sorry
TV between P theta and P theta Prime
this is equal to one-half of the
integral between F theta f theta Prime
and when I don't write it so I don't
write X DX but it's there and then I
integrate over over E okay so what is
this thing doing for me it's just saying
well if I have so think of two gaussians
for example I have one left here and one
that's here okay so this is let's say F
theta F theta Prime this guy is doing
what it's computing the absolute value
of the difference between F theta and F
theta Prime so you can check for
yourself that graphically this I can
represent as an area not under the curve
but between the curves alright so this
is this guy now this guy is really the
integral of the absolute value so this
thing here this area this is two times
the total variation okay thus killing
one half really doesn't matter it's just
if I want to have an actual
correspondence between the maximum and
the and the other guy I have to do this
okay so this is what it looks like so we
have this definition and and so we have
a couple of properties that come into
this the first one is that it's
symmetric TV of P theta and P theta
prime is the same as the TV between P
theta Prime and P theta well that's
pretty obvious from this definition
right I just flipped those two I get the
same number it's actually also true if I
take the maximum all right those things
are completely symmetric in theta and
theta prime can just flip them it's not
negative is that clear to everyone that
this thing is non-negative right I
integrate an absolute value so this
thing is going to give me some
non-negative number and so if I
integrate this non negative number it's
going to be a non-negative number the
fact also that it's an area tells me
that it's going to be non-negative the
nice thing is that if TV is equal to
zero then the two distributions
two probabilities are the same that
means that for every a p theta of a is
equal to p theta prime of a now there's
two ways to see that the first one is to
say that if this integral is equal to
zero then that means that for all almost
all X F theta is equal to F theta Prime
the only way I can integrate a
non-negative function and get zero is
that it fits zero pretty much everywhere
okay and so what it means is that the
two densities have to be the same pretty
much everywhere which means that the
distributions are the same but this is
not really the way you want to do this
because you have to understand what you
know pretty much everywhere means which
I should really say almost every word
that's the formal way of saying it
but let's go to this this to definition
which is gone okay yeah that's the one
here the max of those two guys if this
maximum is equal to zero I have a
maximum of non-negative numbers they're
absolute values right their maximum is
equal to zero well they better be all
equal to zero because if one is not
equal to zero then the maximum is not
equal to okay so those two guys for
those two things to be for the maximum
to be equal to zero then each of the
individual absolute values have to be
equal to zero which means that the
probability here is equal to this
probability here for every event a okay
so those two things this is nice right
that's called definiteness the total
variation equal to 0 implies that P
theta is equal to P theta Prime so
that's really some notion of distance
right that's what we want if this
thing's being small implied that piece
theta could be all over the place
compared to P theta prime that would not
help very much now there's also the
triangle inequality that follows
immediately from the triangle inequality
inside the inside this guy right if I
squeeze in some F theta prime prime in
there I'm gonna use the triangle
inequality and get the triangle
inequality for the whole thing okay
I'll do it for you now okay so let's
just prove that those two things are
actually giving me the same definition
all right so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually going to start with the second
one and I'm gonna write I'm gonna start
with the density version but as an
exercise you can do it for the PMF
version if you prefer so I'm gonna start
with the fact that F okay so I'm gonna
write f of G so I don't have to write
the F and G right so think of this as
being absurd thither and think of this
guy as being F sub theta prime I just
don't want to have to write in this is
all the time okay so I'm gonna start
with this thing the integral of f of X
minus G of X DX okay the first thing I'm
gonna do is this is an absolute value so
either the number in the absolute value
is positive and I actually kept it like
that or it's negative and I flip that
sign okay so let's just split between
those two cases all right so this thing
is equal to 1/2 the integral of so let
me actually write the set a star as
being the set of X's such that f of X is
larger than G of X okay so that's the
set on which the difference is going to
be positive or the difference is going
to be negative right so this again is
equivalent to f of X minus G of X is
positive all right
okay everybody agrees so this is the set
I'm interested in so now I'm going to
split my integral integral into two
parts in a a star so of so on a star f
is larger than G so the absolute value
is just the difference itself so here I
put parentheses rather than absolute
value and then I have plus
one half of the integral of the condor
complement what are you guys used to to
write the compliment to the sea or the
bar to the sea okay and so here on the
compliment then f is less than G so this
is actually really G of X minus f of X
DX okay everybody's with me here so I
just said I mean those are just
rewriting what the definition of the
absolute value is okay so now there's
there's nice things that I know about F
and G and the two nice things is that
the integral of F is equal to 1 and the
integral of G is equal to 1 right this
implies that the integral of F minus G
is equal to what 0 ok and so now that
means that if I want you just go from
the integral here on a compliment to the
integral on a or on a star compliment to
the integral on a star I just have to
flip the sign right so that implies that
an integral on a star compliment of G of
X minus f of X DX this is simply equal
to the integral on a star of f of X
minus G of X DX
okay all right so now this guy becomes
this guy over there all right so I have
one half of this plus one half of the
same guy so it means that one half of
the integral between F we took of F
minus G absolute value so that was my
original definition this thing is
actually equal to the integral on a star
of f of X minus G of X DX okay
and this is simply equal to P of a star
so say p f of a star minus P G of a star
okay
which one is larger than the other one
it is just look at this board what the
first one has to be larger because this
thing is actually equal to a
non-negative number okay so now I have
this absolute value of two things
and so I'm closer to the actual
definition but I still need to show you
that this thing is the maximum value
right so this is definitely at most the
maximum over a of P f of a minus P G of
a that's certainly true right we agree
with this because this is just for one
specific a and I'm bounding it by the
maximum over all possible ways so that's
clearly true so now I have to go the
other way around I have to show you that
the max is actually this guy a star so
why would that be true well let's just
inspect this thing over there all right
so we want to show that if I take any
other a in this integral then this guy a
star it's actually going to decrease its
value so we have this function I'm gonna
call this function Delta okay and what
we have is so let's say this function
looks like this now it's the difference
between two densities it doesn't have to
integrate it doesn't have to be
non-negative but it certainly has to
integrate to zero okay and so now I take
this thing and the a star what is the
set a star here the set a star is the
set over which the function Delta is
non-negative right right so that's just
the definition a star was the set over
which F minus G was positive and F minus
G which is called Delta so what it means
is that what I'm really integrating is
Delta on this set
so it's this area under the curve just
on the positive things agreed
so now let's just make some tiny
variations around this guy if I take a
to be larger than a star right so let me
add for example this part here that
means that when I compute my integral
I'm removing this area under the curve
right it's negative the integral here is
negative so if I start adding something
to a the value goes lower if I start
removing something from a like say this
guy I'm actually removing this value
from the integral so there's no way I'm
actually stuck this a star is the one
that actually maximizes the integral of
this function all right so there was we
use the fact that for any function say
Delta the integral over a of Delta is
less than the integral over the set of
X's such that Delta of X is non-negative
of Delta of X DX okay and that's an
obvious fact just by picture say okay
and that's true for all things
yep
it's actually equal we know that the
integral of F minus G is integral Delta
is zero so there's actually exactly the
same area above and below but you yeah
you're right you could go to the extreme
cases you're right
no it's actually it's actually still be
true even if there was if this was a
constant that would still be true here I
never used the fact that the integral is
equal to zero okay I could shift this
function by one so that the integral of
Delta is equal to one and it still it
would still be true that it's maximized
when I take a to be the set where it's
positive just need to make sure that
there's some place where it is but
that's about it
okay of course we use this but before
when we made this thing but just the
last argument this last fact does not
require that okay all right so now we
have this notion of okay so we have this
notion of distance between probability
measures right I mean this things are
exactly what's if I were to be in a
formal math class and I said here are
the axioms that a distance should
satisfy those are exactly these things
if it's not satisfying this thing it's
called pseudo distance or quasi distance
or just metric or nothing at all
honestly okay so it's a distance it's
symmetric non-negative equal to zero
when if and only if the two arguments
are equal and it satisfies the triangle
inequality all right and so that means
that so we have this actual total
variation distance between travel
distributions and here is now a
statistical strategy to implement our
goal remember our goal was to spit out a
theta hat which was closed so such that
P theta hat
was close to P theta star so hopefully
we're trying to minimize the total
variation distance between piece theta
hat and P theta star now we cannot do
that because just by this fact this this
slide if we wanted to do that directly
we would just take well let's take theta
hat equals theta star and that will give
me the value 0 and that's the minimum
possible value it can take the problem
is that we don't know what the toe
variation is to something that we don't
know we know how to compute all
variations if I give you the two
arguments but here one of the arguments
is not known P theta star is not known
to us so we need to estimate it and so
here's a strategy just build an
estimator of the total variation
distance between P theta and pset estar
for all candidate theta all possible
theta and capital theta all right
now if this is a good estimate then when
I minimize it I should get something
that's close to P theta star alright so
here's the strategy this is my function
that map's theta to the total variation
between P theta and P theta star
I know it's minimized at theta star
right that's definitely P TV of piece
and and the value here the y-axis should
say zero and so I don't know this guy so
I'm gonna estimate it by some estimator
that comes from my data hopefully the
more data I have the better this
estimator is and I'm gonna try to
minimize this estimator now and if the
two things are closed and the minima
should be closed alright that's a pretty
good estimation strategy the problem is
that it's very unclear how you would
build this estimator of TV of the tool
variation right so building estimators
as I said typically consists in
replacing expectations by averages but
there's no simple way of expressing the
total variation distance as the
expectations with respect to theta star
of anything so what we're gonna do is
we're going to move from total variation
distance to another notion of distance
that sort of has the same properties and
the same feeling and the same
motivations as the total variation
distance but for this guy we will be
able to build an estimate for it because
it's actually going to be of the form
expectation of something and we're gonna
be able to replace the expectation by
average and then minimize this average
all right so this surrogates for tall
variation distance is actually called
the kullbackleibler divergence and why
we call it divergence is because it's
actually not a distance it's not gonna
be symmetric to start with okay so this
kullback-leibler or even KL divergence I
will just refer to it as KL is actually
just more convenient but it has some
roots coming from information theory
which I will not delve into but if any
of you is actually a course six students
I'm sure you've seen that in some course
on I know that has any content on
information theory all right so the KL
divergence between two probability
measures P theta and P theta prime and
here as I said it's not gonna be the
symmetric so it's very important for you
to specify which order you stays between
P theta and P theta Prime and it's
different from saying between P theta
Prime and T and P theta and so we
denoted by KL and it's so remember
before we had either the summer or the
integral of one-half of the distance
absolute value of the distance between
the PMF and one-half of the absolute
values of the distances between the
distributed the probability density
functions and now we replace this
absolute value of the distance divided
by two by this weird function write this
function is P theta log P theta divided
by P theta prime that's the function
alright
that's a weird function okay so this was
what we had so that's the TV and the key
all if I use the same notation F and G
is integral of f of X log of f of X over
G of X DX okay it's a bit different
and if I go I go from discreet to
continuous using an interval everybody
can read this everybody's fine with this
is there any you know uncertainty about
the actual definition here so here I go
straight to the definition which is just
plug in the functions into some integral
and compute okay so I don't bother with
Maxima or anything there I mean there is
something like that but it's certainly
not as natural as a tool variation yes
yes just because you it's hard to build
anything from tool variation because I
don't know it right so it's very
difficult but if you can actually and
even computing it between two gaussians
just try it for yourself and you know
please stop doing it after at most six
minutes because you won't be able to do
it and so it's just very hard to
manipulate like this integral of
absolute values of differences between
probability density function at least
for the probability and C functions
we're used to manipulate is actually
your nightmare and so people prefer KL
because for the Gaussian this is going
to be theta minus theta prime squared
and then we're gonna be happy okay and
so those things are much easier to
manipulate but it's really the total
variation is telling you how far in the
worst case the two probabilities can be
this is really the intrinsic notion of
closeness between probabilities so
that's really the one if we could that's
the one we would go after sometimes
people will compute them numerically so
that they can say oh here is the tool
variation distance I have between those
two things and then and then you
actually know that that means they're
close because the absolute value if I
tell you to variation is 0.01 like we
did here it has a very specific meaning
if I tell you the KL divergence is 0.01
it's not clear what it means all right
okay so what are the properties the KL
divergence between P theta and P theta
prime is different from the KL
divergence between P theta Prime and P
theta in general of course in general
because the theta is equal to theta
prime then this certainly is true okay
so there's cases when it's not true okay
the KL divergence is non-negative
who knows the Jensen's inequality here
that should be a subset of the people
who risk their hand when they asked when
I asked what a convex function is all
right so you know what Jensen's
inequality is this is Jensen's the proof
is just one step Jensen's inequality
which will not go into details but
that's basically an inequality involving
expectation of a convex function of a
random variable compares to the convex
function of the expectation of a random
variable all right you can if you know
Jensen have fun and prove it what's
really nice is that if the KL is equal
to zero then the two distributions are
the same and that's something we're
looking for everything else we're happy
to throw out and actually if you pay
attention we're actually really throwing
up everything else so they're not
symmetric it does not try and satisfy
the triangle inequality in general but
it's non-negative and it's 0 if and only
if the two distributions are the same
and that's all we care about and that's
what we call the divergence rather than
a distance because and divergences will
be enough for our purposes ok actually
this asymmetry the fact that it's not
flipping right the first time I saw it I
was just too annoyed I was like can we
just like I don't take the average of
the KL between P theta and piece theta
prime and PCI prime and P theta right
you would think maybe you could do this
right you just symmetrize it by just
taking the average of the 2 possible
values that can take the problem is that
this will still not satisfy the triangle
inequality and there's no way basically
to turn it into something that is a
distance but the divergence is doing a
pretty good thing for us and this is
well what will allow us to estimate it
and basically overcome what we could not
do with the with the total variation all
right
so the first thing that you want to
notice is that two variation distance
the KL divergence re is actually an
expectation of something right look at
what it is here it's the integral of
some function against a density that's
exactly the definition of an int of an
expectation right so this is the
expectation of this particular function
with respect to this
density F so in particular if I call
this density F if I say I want the true
distribution to be the first argument
this is an expectation with respect to
the true distribution from which my data
is actually drawn of the log of this
ratio so haha I'm a statistician now I
have an expectation I can replace it by
an average because I have data from this
distribution and I could actually
replace the expectation by an average
and try to minimize here the problem is
that actually the star here should be in
front of the theta n of the p right
that's piece theta star not P star theta
but here I still cannot compute it
because I have this piece this piece did
I started I chose up I don't know what
it is and that's now where the log plays
a role if you actually pay attention I
said you can use Jensen to prove all
this stuff you could actually replace
the log by any concave function and that
would be a F divergence that's called an
F divergence but the log itself is a
various very specific property which
allows us to say that the log of the
ratio is the ratio of the logs now this
thing here does not depend on theta if I
think of this KL divergence as a
function of theta then the first part is
actually a constant if I change theta
this thing is never going to change
it depends only on theta star so if I
look at this function KL
so if I look at the function data maps
to KL P theta star P theta it's of the
form expectation with respect to theta
star log of P theta star of X and then I
have minus expectation with respect
Taylor star of log of P theta of X now
as I said this thing here this second
expectation is a function of theta when
theta changes this thing is gonna change
and that's a good thing we want
something that reflects our clothes
theta and theta star R but this thing is
not going to change this is a fixed
value it's go actually it's the negative
entropy of P theta star and if you've
heard of KL you've probably heard of
entropy and that's what the it's
basically minus the entropy and that's
the quantity that just depends on theta
star but it's just a number right that
could compute this number if I told you
this is a n theta star one so now I'm
gonna try to minimize the estimate of
this function and minimizing a function
or a function plus a constant is the
same thing right I'm just shifting the
function here here but it's the same
minimizer okay so the function that
map's kiyul to theta 2 T L of P theta
star to P theta is of the form constant
minus this expectation of a log of P
theta everybody agrees are there any
questions about this
are there any remarks including I have
no idea what's happening right now here
you go yeah
so we're not a this is not a method just
yet right I'm just describing to you
what the KL divergence between to
distribution and if you really wanted to
compute it you would need to know what
piece theta stories and what P theta is
and so here I'm just saying at some
point we still so here you see it so now
let's move on to one step
I don't know expectation of theta star
but I have data that comes from
distribution P theta star so the
expectation by the law of large numbers
should be close to the average and so
what I'm doing is I'm replacing any
expand access as a very standard
estimation method you write something as
an expectation with respect to the data
generating process of some function and
then you replace this by the average of
this function and the lower part number
tells me that those two quantities
should actually be close now it doesn't
mean that's gonna be the end of the day
right when we did the xn bar that was
the end of the day we had an expectation
we replaced it by an average and then we
were gone but here we still have to do
something because this is not telling me
what theta is now I still have to
minimize this average okay so this is
now my candidate estimator for TL TL hat
and that's the one where I said well
it's gonna be of the form a constant and
this constant I don't know you're right
I have no idea what this constant is it
depends on piece data star but then I
have minus something that I can
completely compute if you give me data
and theta I can compute this entire
thing and now what I claim is that the
minimizer of F or F was for f of X or f
of X plus 4 are the same thing right or
say 4 plus f of X I'm just shifting the
the plot of my function up and down but
the minimizer stays exactly where it is
right if I think I have a function so
now I have a function of theta
this is kale hat of P theta star T theta
and it's of the form it's a function
like this I don't know where this
function is it might very well be this
function or this function every time
it's a translation on the y-axis of all
these guys and the value that I
translated by depends on theta star I
don't know what it is but what I claim
is that the minimizer is always this guy
regardless of what the value is okay so
when I say constant it's a constant with
respect to theta it's an unknown
constant but it's with respect to theta
so without loss of generality I can
assume that this constant is zero
for my purse Pacific my purposes or 25
if you prefer alright so we'll just keep
going on this property next time and
we'll see how from here we can move on
to the likelihood is actually gonna come
out of this formula Thanks